this situation in the house where no one  has been sworn in and there is no  speaker  it can lead to a functional breakdown of  the House of Representatives the speaker  actually plays a critical role in  managing and organizing the legislative  process and with no speaker how does the  house conduct business and pass  legislation is it possible to do it is  but it's significantly more of a mess  within government no speaker and no  one's sworn in causes uncertainty it  causes instability the speaker is one of  the most powerful and influential  figures or positions in Congress and the  American confidence in government is  certain to decline the uh our perception  of the ability of the house to govern is  quite low accurately because this is  what they're doing